you truly do want to understand somebody
you got to do it from an empathetic kind
of way you got to kind of understand
where they're coming from you got to
kind of listen to them and then you
could formulate a kind of response there
taking some time but you can only open
the door you could only uh you know put
out the water the horse has to drink it
themselves so I I think that's you know
my two cents when it comes to dealing
with family members who don't see eye to
eye to eye with you uh empathy and
understanding goes a long way also just
listening to people goes a very long way
and then you could understand why people
believe a certain idea a lot of it is
usually based on fear a lot of it is
usually based on kind of instincts and
emotions as you were mentioned you're
mentioning
um and and not logical thinking and if
you could you could calm down the
emotions and you could not have that
kind of aggressive stance and you could
just say hey let's let's actually
reassess this maybe at a different time
or hey I don't know what to think about
this what do you think about this uh and
giving people that kind of information
that way could be a lot more conducive
towards waking people up towards the
true reality of this world